bei uns im studio ist ralf schuler reif
wie ist das zu bewerten angela merkel
also in florenz in der toskana gut die
ein könnten jetzt sagen darf sie doch
ruhig sie ist ja nicht mehr im amt
andere sagen wiederum könnte sich
langsam mal äußern das war natürlich ein
sehr hartes geschützt was der
ukrainische präsident aufgefahren hat es
war auch nicht wirklich eine einladung
ist war eigentlich eine rhetorische
figur zu sagen diese toten sind
eigentlich auch die toten der
europäischen russland politik vor allem
der deutschen russlandpolitik er wird
nicht im ernst glauben dass angela
merkel sich dorthin stellt und sich das
grauen dort anguckt auch sarkozy nicht
worauf er anspielt das ist der
nato-gipfel 2008 in bukarest als
georgien und die ukraine mitglied der
nato werden sollten und auch wolken
george hw bush hat damals sehr dafür
geworben sie waren in einem anwärter
programm und es waren namentlich
frankreich vor allem aber auch die
kanzlerin die am ende auch intern sehr
stolz darauf war sich immer wieder mit
der damaligen sicherheitsberaterin
condoleezza rice zurückgezogen zu haben
die beiden sprachen damals übrigens
russisch interessanterweise sowohl preis
als auch merkel sprechen fließend
russisch und merkel hat das den
amerikanern ausgeredet frankreich war
auch dagegen darum spielt der präsident
jetzt an ob es damals gut gewesen wäre
diese beiden länder die schon damals
auch instabil waren aufzunehmen ist eine
ganz andere frage
worauf brasiliens kernpunkt hat ist
natürlich die massive abhängigkeit die
deutschland auch in den jahren danach
noch von russischen rohstoffen und vor
allem von russischem gas aufgebaut hat
das wäre nicht nötig gewesen und da gab
es auch warnungen also das was wir
machen eine ganz kurze woche an dieser
stelle denn uns hat gerade eine breaking
news erreicht
[Musik]
wir schauen nämlich direkt zu sebastian
prill nachhilfe sebastian
bombeneinschläge offensichtlich bei dir
ja das ist richtig also wir sind hier in
st
das ist der stadtbereich von kharkiv der
von den russen am schlimmsten
bombardiert wird es ist eine
hochhaussiedlung hier schlagen also
quasi im sekundentakt raketen bomben und
granaten und es hört einfach nicht auf
das geht hier seit tagen so seit wochen
und man kann sich das nicht vorstellen
aber die ruinen hier die haben keine
fenster mehr kein strom kein gas kein
wasser kein licht nicht aber es gibt
tatsächlich immer noch menschen die hier
aus haben wir waren gerade eben bei
einer älteren dame in der wohnung der
frau hat drei katzen und die tiere sind
das einzige was ihr geblieben sind und
deshalb will sie hier nicht weg und es
gibt tatsächlich freiwillige die diese
menschen hier nicht im stich lassen und
mit essen versorgen aber wir hören dass
auch im hintergrund also es ist wirklich
fürchterlich die sind diesen
bombenterror hier im prinzip schutzlos
ausgeliefert die zahlen der menschen die
jetzt hier noch in der stadt sind die
sind widersprüchlich manche sprechen von
einer million andere von 500.000 manche
sagen sogar 80 prozent der bevölkerung
haben die stadt verlassen viele harren
auch in der metro aus das sind hier in
rackith wirklich katastrophale zustände
und eine sache ist mir auch wichtig zu
sagen dass hier hat wirklich nichts mit
mir zu tun hier gibt es keine truppen
hier gibt es keine kasernen hier gibt es
keine stellung das ist ein reines
wohngebiet und das wird von putin hier
in schutt und asche gelegt was ist
wirklich schrecklich man hörte es immer
wieder hinter dir diese bombeneinschläge
kann es uns einmal kurz neigen wo du da
gerade genau stehst
ich glaube das wird schwierig weil die
verbindung wirklich sehr schlecht ist
aber vielleicht kann der kameramann
einmal einmal schwenken jetzt kommen die
einschläge wirklich extrem nah
das ist eine so genannte
grad-rakete das heißt übersetzt hagel
und das sind also ist ein raketenwerfer
im prinzip die nach der nachfolger der
der sogenannten stalin orgel und sie
schlagen hier dann wirklich innerhalb
weniger sekunden 1 sebastian bitte bring
dich in sicherheit wenn es sein muss das
geht natürlich definitiv vor an dieser
stelle
da ist die verbindung auch wegfielen
dank sebastian buch das ist wirklich
eindrücklich was man was man da sieht
dass man damit bekommt ralf schuler
weiterhin bei uns im studio ja unter
diesen gesichtspunkten jetzt in die
ukraine zu reisen so wie es jetzt zum
beispiel ursula von der leyen
angekündigt hat das ist dann schon
wieder doch ein starkes zeichen oder das
ist ein sehr starkes zeichen europa
steht zur ukraine
das ist eigentlich das stärkste was man
bislang aus brüssel vernommen hat und
wenn das so stattfindet ist das schon
sehr bemerkenswert
auch weil die ukraine ja gerne mitglied
der europäischen union werden will was
so einfach nicht ist aber als zeichen
der rückendeckung ist das schon ganz
stark die kanzlerin hat kein mandat mehr
es gibt leute die sagen sie sollte
vermitteln sie selbst ist da eher
zurückhaltend denn sie war nicht sehr
erfolgreich sie hat man intern gesagt
vor einiger zeit sie habe keinem
staatsmann so viel zeit so viel energie
gewidmet wie wladimir putin und niemand
habe sie so oft belogen und betrogen wie
wladimir putin eine späte erkenntnis zu
der mann aus meiner sicht früher hätte
kommen können hätte man auch ohne
konsequenzen ziehen und es gab auch
warnungen nicht nur polen hat schon von
anfang der 2010er jahre immer wieder
gewarnt den gasbezug weiter auszubauen
es gab auch im rahmen des europäischen
rates anderen europäischen ländern die
sagten warum macht ihr das warum macht
ihr euch so abhängig warum bleibt ihr
nicht energiepolitisch autark
folgemilch
ja die kanzlerin hat lange darauf
gewartet kein amt mehr zu haben und
endlich die stätten zu bereisen die sie
im amt zwar gesehen aber nicht wirklich
hat angucken können und da gehört auch
florenz mit dazu sie ist eine große
italien liebhaberin eine toskaner
liebhaberin mit florenz verbindet sie
unter anderem der frühere italienische
ministerpräsident matteo renzi der dort
mal oberbürgermeister war und den sich
schon ins kanzleramt eingeladen hatte
als er noch ein politisches talent war
und dann später ein wo der
ministerpräsident hat sich auch sehr
enge kontakte gepflegt hier ist sie ganz
offensichtlich mit frau schavan die war
früher botschafterin am vatikan nachdem
sie wegen der abgeschriebenen
doktorarbeit aus dem amt geschieden war
lange vertraute von merkel es sind noch
einige professoren aus der berliner
wissenschafts community dabei ihr mann
allerdings nicht man habe nicht dabei er
war wohl am wochenende auch dort hat
allerdings eine gastprofessor in turin
und möglicherweise ist er dort wieder
jetzt die woche über da kann man nur
spekulieren offizielle angaben gibt es
darüber nicht aber merkel hat
bekanntermaßen eine vorliebe für
alte griechische alte römische kunst und
die lebensart in der toskana kommt ja
auch sehr hingegen chianti analog
trotzdem muss man glaube ich hier ein
ständig sagen ein wahrlich schlechter
zeitpunkt also der gegenschnitt ist
nicht besonders günstig gut danke ralf
schüler für deine einschätzung